[Music]
hey what's up what is
this younger nades it's owners with gq
you already know what's going on
[Music]
oh my first piece i ain't even got my
first piece i'm on my first piece i
ended up giving it to my brother
queso a while back but my second piece
that i got was
this piece right here it's uh my tattoo
i got my net it's my first tattoo i ever
got it's like it's an ace of spade
with a with wings on it and with a
inside of you know what i'm saying
so it's like something i stand on like
me like you know what i'm saying just
like
it just represent me you know what i'm
saying i got this chain probably like
two two three years ago i don't
even remember the pricing probably like
15 probably
something like that because it's the
type of diamonds you know you know what
i'm saying they real high quality
diamonds this chain right from cinema
it's lay my moment johnny schatz gave me
this he gifted me this for christmas
i'm saying on the back of it say uh it's
okay that's kind of rude to ask people
how much
how much something costs or something
like that but he always tell me like
that's the expensive change
it's been some very expensive like [ __ ]
like that but my favorite piece
is the piece that i got on driveway
every day iceman did this it's
atk you know what i'm saying it's my
brand well my team brand like you know
what i'm saying we came up with this
from scratch
and i got like like four other smaller
ones for my team you know what i'm
saying everybody on my team my brothers
and stuff like that
but this one costs like 30. you know
what i'm saying still to the day
everybody keep asking me what atk me
everybody come up with they own the
names don't nobody in the world know
what atk me
i got like everybody all my fans and
everybody in the world screaming atk but
nobody know what they screaming for real
you know what i'm saying so i don't
really like telling people to meet him
because it's a real big meaning behind
it you know what i'm saying
i plan on keeping that way for a little
minute i mean eventually i'm gonna come
out
and say what's the real meaning behind
it but like right now i'm just i'm just
vibing right now
oh see now this this this chain right
it's a bit 23 chain
see my little brother who passed away
right y'all 23.
now i'm saying well my uh you're my best
friend actually so
it's a big 23 form this was one of my
favorite channels as well because
it represent my best friend femi i put
on time time
i put them on just a like a little
comfort you know what i'm saying
this probably like 25 too see how you
got the red diamonds with them
yeah i read down the 23. it stand out
the most because of the color
this is my third chain i got this
representing my brothers who who had
passed away
like two times 23 fo
and my brother momo and it's a mirror
behind the folks like the mirror it's
like i see me
you know what i'm saying it's the way i
came up with something like that
straight ice did this check the chain
probably went up for probably like ten
thousand something like that
but it means a lot to me though i i
barely wear it because i try to like
cherish it more you know what i'm saying
i miss my brothers all the time but when
i get like a real like i had them days
and i probably
put this on and i throw this chain on
with it you know what i'm saying
[Music]
it's that chain right here this that
tennis this is my favorite chain because
i
i like the way they got diamonds all the
way around you know i'm saying
this is before i even know cuban can get
bust down i actually just think cuba
is just like the gold cuban like you
know what i'm saying this could fit all
the other chains like this i could put
this on there so
i might switch it up and put the other
ones on there you know what i'm saying i
actually got like two of these
our cuban cuban cuba link and i put
these like right on top of it
i like 15. the other one was probably
like 10.
this is the first cuban i ever got but
this people ain't 30 right hell
and this one i got this chain right here
the atk chain so i'm like okay i know if
i get the big atk chain i got to get the
cube link
you know what i'm saying i like white
for some reason like white
shine shine more to me than like the
gold you feel me
that's like a trophy too like you know
what i'm saying like a hood truck
everybody wants cuban links and like
diamonds and golds you know what i'm
saying
so this is a big accomplishment for me
right ain't gonna lie
i ain't gonna lie i just got this change
not even a month ago
i pulled up and i've seen it i just like
damn i like that chain
this chain right here this is not this
is 9500
9500 yup so when i take it home
to my girlfriend chloe see right she
like she loved jerry femin
so she's just taking the automatic just
put it on she didn't take it off she had
on for like a week straight so i never
got
still today i never wore yet it's
another cute little
difference between this one they got
spaghettis and baguettes
i call them baguettes and it's like
tucson they got rose gold and they got
white
this one was 28 000. and this is
probably like
one of my favorite ones just because i
don't know because it's two-toned but i
ain't even like baguettes like that
it's the lock all the cubans got so if
somebody pull it you're gonna go with it
because it got that powerful lock
once they go in here it's locked you
can't take this apart no matter what you
do
tugging it whatever i have as hard as
you can
and this cube link right here this is my
favorite cube length right used to be
these tender chains
but these shine moves i like to see that
shine this one was 32 just keep man it's
a bit cute man
like it's more wide you know what i'm
saying and i wear this with this one
because it fit it just fits so perfect
together you know what i'm saying it's
just like it matches
this guy a lot too can't pull that
either feel me i wear all three cuban
legs
i'd be looking crazy like a disco ball
all right this is a cardio watch i got
this for my birthday
2020. actually my boy king vaughn
recipes came on he the one who told me
to uh
to get it so i was asking him like which
one should i get you like nobody really
got the car there yeah this was
this around town when nobody didn't
really have it you know what i'm saying
so i end up getting it
and like [ __ ] i ain't gonna lie took it
off since it's my favorite watch
but this watch was like 23 000. i got
this from izzy in new york here in new
york
i supposed to be at double xl when i'm
in them i'm trying i'm so fascinated by
the watts
i'm around the corner i'm probably like
10 minutes from double xl
around the corner late the double sl
trying to get my watch that's when i got
this cuban link bracelet
i got these on the same day on the same
press it's
this is like my fourth bracelet i got
this 9500 for sure
had me late double xl for these right
i'm telling you my label was hot
they were hot they don't even want to
look at it they so mad because they know
i'm late because of the jury
but look i still got the watch
i see my ring right here see this one
got the ace
and it got the spade symbol behind it i
got this custom made
actually this ring mean like like like a
championship
the [ __ ] that i accomplished throughout
my life so like
the boss all these little rings real i
got them from mike
his name ice man mike these aren't even
got no meaning to i just like the way
they were signing their diamonds there
were you know i just wanted to spend
some money so i'm like oh yeah i want
that ring let me see that
i want that one too you know what i'm
saying i ain't even realize how serious
the customizing uh stuff was until like
like recently i started getting into the
jury you know what i'm saying
they probably cost like uh like 7 500 a
piece something like that
yeah i know this one will probably like
five right here this one 65
75 because it's customized
this first thing i got when i got a
release from jail
i had to get down i got my whole mouth
though like she was saying
i got my whole mouth all like while
that's like a little florida thing that
we get
we get our whole mouth and he's like
dirty you know i'm saying
shot johnny dang john dane's diamonds
his grills go
too crazy i don't think nobody nobody
game with his diamonds
i ain't gonna lie when i first got him i
just like i was smiling there i wanted
everybody know i had easy going
even when i'm mad i'd be smiling say
something so crazy because i didn't even
know
what none of this stuff was like i know
it's jury like okay i'm like oh yeah i
want change but i ain't never know the
difference between a chain like i said
like
i barely be knowing the name still to
right now i just if i like it i'm buying
it you know what i'm saying
i always wanted like a maybe a
lamborghini
ferrari you know what i'm saying is more
of a cod for me but i always wanted jury
too like i said i want the jury
but i just didn't know what it was
called femi i ain't take the time to
invest and just
looking to the jury i appreciate y'all
for watching me talk about my jury and
i'm saying
real ice real water you feeling i make
sure i check out life but trail two
times
let me know